hello fellow geeks this is zacky from
geek culture and boy we have something
we can't wait to show you guys this is
an exclusive global review of two new
transformers toys courtesy of the good
folks at hasbro singapore first up we
have the transformers generation selects
voyager class megatron inspired from the
original g2 release way back in 1992 the
figure comes with a swat and fusion
cannon accessory and transforms from
robot to tank mode in just 21 steps so
here we go
[Music]
necessary
yes
[Music]
so
and the second figure we have is the
voyager class sandstorm this
long-awaited figure was inspired by a
mock-up and was never released as a g2
figure featuring desert camo style
paintwork and a ferocious shark mouth
design on the nose of the jet mode this
figure comes in two non-rare accessories
and transforms from robot mode to jet
mode in just 25 steps so let's get on to
it
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
well there you have it the transformers
generation selects
voyager class megatron and sandstorm and
in case you're wondering these two
figures are slated to be launched on the
1st of december 2020 ah now where do we
put
i think i got a perfect spot to hold
these two guys
yeah this is going whole
g
right there right
there
awesome
if you guys enjoyed this video don't
forget to like comment share and
subscribe and smash that notification
bell icon so you can stay updated to the
latest toys reviews and geeky tidbits
until then this is zacky
[Music]
you